we are the first top-tier law firm to
launch an entire division dedicated to
superhuman law oh my god is this why
they hired me okay this sucks i am
totally qualified but now everyone
around here is always gonna think this
is the only reason i got the job it's so
unfair
should be able to enjoy the fact that i
just got an amazing new job and i can't
these dodos never had to deal with this
on their first day at work but i'm
curious
what do you think about it
i'm
uh
agnostic
interesting
unprecedented for sure
oh
i'll spend the rest of the year worrying
about what i just said
hi
everybody you're gonna fire him chad
chad
you said to bring it up i said don't
bring it up why would i tell you to
bring it up sorry uncle mom she already
feels like complete crud it's okay dad i
yes got fired but it's fine is the
nicest young man who works at the coffee
shop that i go to his name is yusuf not
sent me in no he's much too young for
you no he wants to be a superhero and i
told him that my daughter was a
superhero he hadn't heard of you but i
gave him your number so that he could
call you for advice please stop giving
my number out to strangers again uh that
hawkeye guy
what happens to those arrows of his i
mean does he go around and collect them
when he's done jenny nobody calls me now
i'm just gonna put this out there
melanie
is a stylist you know
she could help you let's get this hair
more like she-hulks
so back to hawkeye it's pretty hazardous
to believe those things lying around
there's a couple things i could use your
help
you